LATER WE WILL CHECK ON SLEEP
BEAT JOE BIDEN, STILL
CAMPAIGNING IN HIS BASEMENT.
NOT VERY WELL.
THE PERSON THAT REPRESENTS
EVERYTHING WRONG IN THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP, NANCY PELOSI.
THEY HAVE BEEN TOTALLY
COMPLETELY MISSING, SHELTERING
AND MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
COMMUNITIES.
TURNS OUT, THEY WERE BUSY BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS COMPLETING THIS.
A 347,000 WORD WISHLIST FILLED
WITH $3 TRILLION AND MORE
SPENDING.
THE 4 TRILLION IN LOAN
GUARANTEES FROM THE FEDS.
DESPITE CALLING IT A COVERT
RELIEF BILL, WELL, THE PROPOSAL
IS ABSOLUTELY ZERO TO DO WITH
ONGOING PANDEMIC.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE
TREATING THE CORONAVIRUS LOOK
IT’S CHRISTMAS MORNING.
IT JUST LIKE THEY DID WHEN THEY
KEPT HOSPITAL WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES WAITING FOR THE FIRST
STIMULUS BILL.
A MEMBER THAT, A WEEK AND A
HALF.
THIS ONE, THEY WANT $20 MILLION
FOR ARTS AND HUMANITIES
FOUNDATION.
50,000 FOR COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITIES.
4.6 MILLION FOR THE VOTING FEE.
$25 BILLION FOR THE POST OFFICE.
$1 TRILLION BLANK CHECK.
$1 TRILLION TO BAIL OUT FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE STATES AND
GOVERNMENTS.
OTHER WORDS, YOUR HARD-EARNED
TAX DOLLARS.
TO PAY OFF MOSTLY NEW YORK,
CALIFORNIA, ILLINOIS.
THIS INCLUDES UNFUNDED PENSIONS.
THIS INCLUDES THEIR RECKLESS
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS.
WASTING MONEY AFTER THEY TAX
THEIR STATE AND CHASE EVERYBODY
OUT OF THEIR STATE.
A LOOK AT YORK FOR EXAMPLE.
A SOLAR POWER PLANT, YEAH, THAT
WENT BELLY UP ALSO.
NOW, ELON MUSK OWNS IT.
THE $12,000 TRANSIT EMPLOYEES
MAKING A HUNDRED GRAND EACH PER
YEAR.
A PROGRAM IN ILLINOIS THAT
ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO RIDE
BICYCLES.
NEW YORK STATE, THEY SPENT AN
ESTIMATED $7.5 BILLION ON THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ANNUALLY.
NEW YORK CITY JUST PASSED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BILL TO
COVER THE MEDICAL COSTS OF ALL
OF ITS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
RESIDENTS.
IN THE SANCTUARY STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THEY PAY OUT A
WHOPPING $23 BILLION EACH YEAR
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT TO BE YOUR
TAX DOLLARS SPENT BAILING OUT?
BECAUSE THAT’S WHERE IT WILL GO.
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE STATES,
THEY SHOULD DEMAND THAT THEIR
CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN AND THEIR
SENATORS REJECT THIS.
IT IS LITERALLY ROBBING FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
THANKFULLY, PELOSI’S MONEY GRAB
DOESN’T HAVE A SNOWBALL’S CHANCE
IN.
LEAST AS OF NOW.
OF BECOMING LAW.
ANOTHER POLITICAL STUNT.
EVEN PELOSI HERSELF, SHE CAN’T
EVEN SELL HER OWN BAD BILL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MINORITY LEADER CALLED IT A
LIBERAL WISH LIST OF A BUNCH OF
ITEMS THAT YOU WANTED TO HAVE
PASSED.
EVEN BEFORE THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC.
HAPPENED.
>> I KNOW THAT’S WHAT HE SAID.
I CAN’T BE BOTHERED ABOUT
WHETHER -- WHAT I’M PROUD OF IS
WHAT WE ARE DOING.
OUR COSTS HAVE AGREED THAT
EVERYTHING IS CORONAVIRUS
CENTRIC AND ALSO A WAY THAT
RELATES TO THE VIRUS.
TO OUR LIVES, TO OUR LIVELIHOOD,
TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Sean: KEEP IN MIND, THIS
CALLS FOR A TRILLION DOLLARS
JUST FOR STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND $10 BILLION FOR SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS.
SHE HAS NO SHAME, THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY HAS NO SHAME.
NEVER LET A CRISIS GO TO WASTE.
BECAUSE YOU WILL GET THINGS DONE
YOU NEVER DREAMED IT COULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
INSTEAD OF SERIOUSLY WORKING TO
MAKE THIS COUNTRY A BETTER
PLACE, OPENING UP THE COUNTRY
SAFELY, BEING PRODUCTIVE, JUST
LIKE THEY HAVE FOR THREE PLUS
YEARS, NOPE.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS BECOME
OBSTACLES.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO -- THEY ARE
NOT HELPING PEOPLE RECOVER FROM
THE PANDEMIC.